and let's start here the biden
administration reportedly is planning to
house up to 3 000 migrant teenagers at
the dallas convention center
as it struggles to find more space for
the surge of migrants overwhelming our
immigration system
the dallas site will be used for up to
90 days starting as soon as next week
according to a memo obtained by the
associated press
this is a new york times report raises
alarm about the conditions
some of the kids are living in at border
facilities including being forced to
sleep on
gym mats with foil sheets and go for
days without showers
meanwhile house minority leader kevin
mccarthy
has visited one of those migrant
detention facilities in texas
and went after president biden said he
should visit the border himself to see
what his policies have created
it's more than a crisis
this is a human heartbreak the sad part
about all of this
it didn't have to happen this crisis is
created by the presidential policies
of this new administration there's no
other way to claim it
than abiding border crisis
but dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
echoed the white house in blaming former
president trump's policies for the
search
while also dismissing security concerns
the border is secure the united states
border patrol
secures the border on behalf of the
american people that's what we
do and we are doing it in order to keep
the american public
safe give us the time to rebuild the
system
that was entirely dismantled in the
prior administration
however mayorkas also warned that dhs is
on pace to encounter more individuals on
the southwest border
than we've seen in the past 20 years
you're watching outnumbered
i'm harris faulkner here today my
co-host emily compagno host of no
interruption on fox nation tommy laron
former state department spokesperson
morgan ortegas
and joining us today publisher of the
federalist host of the federalist radio
hour
and fox news contributor now ben
dominesh good to see everybody
um ben there is no spinning
of what's happening all you have to do
is
go to the border and we've had plenty of
people do that take a peek at it tommy
lahren's been down there i have a house
not far from there
why don't we put my yorkis on a gym mat
cover him in some foil
let him not shower for a week and see if
he knows more ideas on how to deal with
the situation
well that's certainly one way to
approach it harris it's great to be with
you of course as always
look what we see on the border happening
now is not happening
thanks to the previous administration's
policies it's happening
because of the incentives that the biden
administration
put in place it's why we saw the numbers
spike in january and february far
earlier than you would expect in a
normal year and it's why we're going to
be dealing with this problem in in
a series of of escalating domino effects
over the coming weeks and months i think
that one of the things we need to
understand is that
under president trump the attitude
towards mexico was essentially very
simple
take care of this problem on your own
southern border so that we don't have to
deal with it on ours
and that was an approach that really
worked for a lot of different reasons
not just because it was in the interests
of mexico to secure their southern
border
but also because they were facing the
ramifications of trade threats and
other pressure that could be put on them
from the trump administration
this was obviously an approach that the
left and the media completely decried
they just
they said that it was inhumane they said
that it was terrible well
what's the what's the humanity factor
now when you see
this enormous wave of human trafficking
which is what this is
that is going to fuel uh the the cartels
that are currently
in the midst of a major drug conflict a
drug war that's happening in mexico
right on the other side of our southern
border this is a chaotic situation
and no amount of excuses from maliorcis
or anyone else within
this administration is going to be able
to get away from the fact that this is a
direct result
of their policy decisions by the way
everybody we are looking
uh live right now outside that
convention center in dallas where they
plan to fill the place up with
teenage migrants coming illegally into
this country
uh morgan
yes ma'am your top line thoughts
so it's interesting harris you talked
about a dismantling of the system
uh early on with the what the biden
administration talked about
and there was a dismantling of the
system but it wasn't by the trump
administration
if you if you'll let me be wonky for a
second there was something that we
negotiated at the state department and
in dhs during the trump administration
two agreements
they're called acas asylum cooperation
agreements
and a bsa a border security agreement we
negotiated these with guatemala
honduras and el salvador and i spoke to
a senior dhs official from the trump
administration this morning we were
talking about this
he told me that they repeatedly warned
the biden transition team not to
unilaterally get rid of these agreements
these were not one-way agreements these
were multi-uh
by par excuse me bilateral agreements
between the united states and these
three countries
related to uh exactly this to border
security to asylum
they were all signed in 2019 and one of
the reasons that we're
seeing the influx today is because the
biden administration decided to get rid
of these two acas and the bsa with
guatemala honduras and el salvador
and they had nothing in place nothing
else was negotiated
uh with these three countries and so
again it's a little bit of a wonky point
but i think it's worth knowing that the
trump dhs
team did warn the incoming biden team
that there will be a surge in the border
if you get rid of these agreements with
these
three countries without anything in
place i want to press in
and i would never call you wonky you are
educating us with the facts
and that counts and as a journalist
that's all i ever really care about
um so i want to ask not only did the
former president trump
negotiate these acas and bsa with these
three countries guatemala
honduras and el salvador but as i
remember
and and reported on he negotiated
through some tough talk
the keep them in mexico pending asylum
uh requests deal with the
the mexican president that wasn't easy
to get i'm gonna guess that these things
weren't easy to get
so taking these things apart uh
did what and and did they know not to
touch those points you say you gave them
a heads up
yeah so i i think harris you know we
approached in the trump administration
we approached our foreign policy from a
position of strength so when we were
going to deal with mexico with guatemala
with honduras with el salvador
on any issues remember that president
trump was not only able to negotiate
these acas and bsas and and the
agreements with mexico
he was also able to renegotiate the
trade agreement with mexico something
that people thought would never happen
uh when a when a leftist president was
elected uh in mexico
and so it is not by again it's important
to note when you approach foreign policy
with these countries from a position of
strength
and you say we are no longer going to
allow this at our border and you
actually mean it
and you follow up uh with meaningful
agreements with meaningful force i was
at the state department podium
when i had to announce that we were
cutting funding to the northern triangle
countries
it wasn't an easy day for me to have to
announce that but we needed these
countries to know that we meant business
tommy yeah no and i agree
wholeheartedly with that and i think
that's an excellent point that needs to
be made you know
back in the trump administration he did
threaten mexico with a tariff
that would be increasing if they didn't
handle their border problem and as i
told you guys
last time i was on and showed the
footage that made mexico cooperate
and then back when the caravans were
coming through at the california area
and coming through tijuana
the folks in tijuana were not happy they
did not want those individuals there
they didn't want that stressing their
economy their infrastructure
their law enforcement so they started to
get tough and things started to change
because the trump administration took a
position of strength another thing i'd
like to discuss here too
is talking about the cartel and the
criminal organizations
while they're funneling all these people
through through human trafficking and
sometimes sex
trafficking and making a lot of money
off of these individuals
and their desire to get to the united
states and take advantage of our perks
and programs
these drug cartels and these criminal
organizations are not just getting
people across
they're using people and they're putting
them through all in a single area and
overwhelming the system so those border
patrol agents
have to play babysitter and they have to
take care of those people coming over
and then when while they're occupied
with that they're bringing the drugs
through so i hope the american people
understand that you know we're in the
middle of a pandemic but we're also in
the middle of an opioid epidemic
and a drug crisis in this country and
that those drugs that are coming over
with those criminal organizations
they're using these people as a shield
and a distraction
and then they're sending through all
these drugs now last year when i visited
mcallen or december
2019 when i visited mcallen texas after
the trump administration and his tough
policies were put in place
border patrol agents are telling me
we're always going to deal with criminal
organizations we're always going to deal
with cartel
trying to get drugs over here but now
our agents can focus on that
and we're not focused on being
babysitters running people to the
hospital running people to detention
centers
processing people so again this is
bigger than just the migrants coming
over
it's also drugs it's a national security
issue it's a border security issue
and it's going to be an issue not just
in border states but all across this
country that stuff is just going to flow
upwards
country which is why you see the
attorneys general and
places like montana joining a lawsuit
with arizona because they know
that the the meth that's coming across
and and those other drugs coming across
into our country goes through that
corridor and they've seen such a spike
of that drug type crime in their state
of montana
uh former white house press secretary
sarah sanders joined me last hour and
she talked about
what's going on at the southern border
watch
when president trump instituted the
remain in pol
remain in mexico policy and put up a
border wall it was effective
and it worked president biden's
administration has
actually caused a humanitarian and
national crisis
at our border by opening them up at a
time when democrats are fighting
to keep our schools our businesses and
our churches closed
they're completely opening our border
it's a total disgrace
look emily um one of the new york
congressmen has said
that the president is aiding and
embedding in the crime of human
trafficking
with his policies something similar to
what you just heard from sarah sanders
right i think at a minimum it's
construed as enablement harris
and i'd like to dig a little deeper on
these capacity locations here so we know
that the administration is opening a
temporary facility
in midland texas right at a camp for
former oil field workers
we know that a proposal is being
considered for the nasa site in moffett
field that's in silicon valley
california
and now in homestead florida a place of
former holdings for up to 1700 migrant
children that's now in quote warm status
now what do these all have in common
they are nowhere near that southern
border
so each of those locations bring with
them a whole host of considerations
for logistics for cost and for covet
exposure
and note it's not just about the the
administration
having control over these temporary
facilities private operators along the
border this is important
private operators along the southern
border have expressed
the fact that they expect increases in
the surge through june
and that there is quote no plan in place
by this administration to deal with them
they are left out in the wind by
themselves in quick final point
it is not just us who are talking about
this and calling for some type of action
specificity or plan on the part of this
administration as the attorneys who have
been granted restricted access down
there
as well as the aclu have demanded that
this administration essentially get
their act together